so with the current happenings
throughout the manga and sukuna you know
decided to cheat code the absolute hell
out of megami's body I think we should
all jump back and take a look at the
very first time we witnessed the
spectacle that is the eight-handled
sword Divergent solid Divine general
maharaga and this monolithic creatures
battle against another ancient figure
inside of the Jujutsu kaising Universe
yes today we are revisiting one of the
most hyped battles to come out of the
Shibuya into an arc the illustrious 15
fingers Kona verse the god shakagami
maharaga obviously I shan't even need to
say this but just use two guys in season
2 and just like massive spoilers in
general as who knows what else I might
allude to here but sit back and relax as
we watch half of Shibuya get wiped from
reality so funnily enough we don't
actually just start off straight with
the battle here before that I need to go
over the moments that lead up to the
historic fight following megami's
peculiar fire with his own resurrected
father he notices that the dude's face
has randomly changed back questioning
why toji would have just you know done
that when he uh committed Kuma's side he
pushes other side to focus on fighting
the others only to be suddenly assaulted
by the luckiest creep on the planet
haruta shikimo the curse user slash is
making me from behind with his hand
sword cursed tool dropping him to the
floor and seemingly ending his run so
skipping away from Mega me and after
seeing what everyone else is up to in
Shibuya for you know a few chapters here
we skip back to see that migami has
somehow managed to get back up and begun
to hobble away from the creep as we
learned earlier on in this series the
teen Shadows technique begins when a
sorcerer receives two Divine dogs mikimi
explains that in order to use the other
shikhigami the sorcerer must work
together with his dogs who take down and
exercise them this way they gain more
and more time to shikigami or with
different types of utilities however
they are limited to a maximum of only
10. wondering if he's finished
explaining this useless information to
him shigumo explains himself that nobara
and his previous fight was also pretty
strong to him it's surprising how young
but strong everyone is here he knows
that Mega me is already on his last legs
still he doesn't see an opening to get
in and land the finishing blow moments
later as he just suspected though making
me collapses to the floor after losing
too much blood man isn't done though
crawling now he continues with his
previous round so you see guys the thing
is you can actually Implement help from
other people to take down a chicken Army
but they also nullifies the technique's
ritual effect for a sorcerer it may seem
like a pointless exorcism with wasted
energy however my waves even a pointless
exorcism is important if you use
correctly weebs and djings alike do you
all know the exact reason as to why the
Gojo family and these Indians are all on
bad terms right here obviously you
probably don't as was never explained
before this moment in the manga or only
alluded to but according to Gojo it was
during the Edo period maybe maybe later
but that man is nonetheless throughout
their time period the respective heads
of each household killed each other in a
fight before the aristocracy just like
in today's climate back then the Gojo
family had someone of great power with a
limitless curse technique and Sex Lies
still they were taken out by user the 10
Shadows technique like Mega me beckon
ship yeah and in a moment of utter
despair now making me bit their back
then the kid of these enemies probably
use this technique in a similar way blah
blah blah blah blah feet up and just
done with it all now shikamo just gets
annoyed with migami's ramblings when all
of a sudden the entirety of this city
begins to rumble jokes it doesn't uh
there's a mega me though it's just old
sakona going absolutely ham in the
distance with his current battle against
jogo shikamo is momentarily distracted
by the nearby clash between them and by
the time he turns his attention back to
Megami the sorcerer has finished
revealing his technique well his hands
together he states that you can't use
the shikigami unless you exercise it but
you can summon them at any time you want
for that said ritual attempt not a
single sorcerer to ever use the 10
Shadows technique had ever been able to
take this creature under their control
realizing like the mistake of his ways
shikimo rushes forth and attempt to stop
him this time though and as the Wolves
begin to howl making me states that with
this treasure I summon eight handles
sword Divergent solid Divine General
maharan forced to take part in this
exorcism ritual sugar understands he and
mikami have to defeat maharaga to
survive however Megami himself knows
that he's far too injured and in that
moment he apologizes to Yuji for what's
about to come looking at his opponent
making me mockingly wishes him good luck
as he'll be the first to pass on here
and instead maharaga violently knocks
Mega me aside sending him shooting into
a nearby building leaving him completely
incapacitated turning around maharaga
sets a sight on shikimo next causing him
to panic and scream for Mega me to wake
back up sukuna who as I said was nearby
doing our Joker one just before notices
her situation and while in
mid-conversation with a roommate tells
his friend that he has to go deal with
some urgent business before leaving
though screening remarks said it really
won't be long until he's completely free
in and in matter of milliseconds uses
his immense speed to rescue sugar mode
before he's crushed by maharaga's
thundering strike rolling up next to
Mega me who's just wasted up against the
wall he notices that the kids in a
suspended state of death so pretty much
a coma thus in his eyes it was most
likely a good idea to save the photo
loser who was dragged into the exorcism
ritual by rescuing the curse user sukuna
avoided ending the ritual saving
migami's life sukuna confirms that his
hunch was right and recognizes the crazy
situation making me is currently in he's
also concerned for the dude's health and
uses his reverse curse technique to save
him while telling the young sorcerer to
not die as there's still something he
needs him to do the cement the safety of
Mega me as man will die if the actual
ritual fails at all sukuna knows that
even as an outsider to the whole thing
he has to defeat maharaga Here and Now
initiating the battle against the 15th
finger sakoda maharaga slammed his blade
down causing the ground to begin
cracking under the pressure exerted on
sakuna and singed in a Shockwave their
blast Jiggy Mo bad while blocking a
weird energy begins to flow from the
blade concerning sukuna flipping out of
the way the king of curses avoids
maharaga's evolving sword seeing the
neck crashing into the ground below
while upside down and media now she
couldn't deliver several rapid fire
straight punches towards opponent's chin
before he lands behind on the floor so
Kona finishes his combination attack by
using one of his no one curse technique
abilities dismantle instantly maharaga's
body is sliced with several deep gashes
causing the monolithic creature to
momentarily fall down on one knee having
taken the time to study his opponent
screen recognizes the shukigami's weapon
as his sword of extermination an
Infamous curse talk used by curse
spirits that emits positive energy he
even admits that it would make short
work of any normal cursed Spirit however
he isn't exactly normal returning to the
battle the eight-handed wheel on my
haragus head turns counterclockwise and
suddenly all of its injuries are healed
sukuna notices this and curious about
what could happen next immediately
attacks with another slash and an insane
twist maharaga easily manages to deflect
it for the sort of extermination
surprising sakuna as he notes that the
sugar garment can now see his cursed
technique maharaga prepares to send
forth another massive swing and Cena
Chucks up his guard in preparation this
time another change of events Maharaja
comfortably breaks clean through
sakona's block and says him crashing
through numerous buildings across
Shibuya while the Ferocious speed
maharaga follows him into an office
building and adds liquid jokes that you
know he wasn't too bad the sort of
extermination passes through the nearby
opening and takes the king of curses by
surprise nearly stabbing sakuna through
the face and one of those like holy [__]
I got a duck moment saguna aerobatically
flips out of the way to avoid getting
hurt it carries his momentum into a
spinning kick that connects and snaps
maharagus head back dropping down screen
of mouse or shikigami's arm before
placing his hand on the target's face
and charging her with curse energy
declaring that it's his turn suguna
unleashes a massive slash that cuts the
entire building in Half while slicing
vertically down maharagus body who has
also seen crashing out of the collapsing
structure by the technique while
maharaga is still shooting back in
mid-air saguna capitalizes following up
with a powerful ax kick that sends his
opponent crashing down several hundred
feet into the ground below believing
that he's probably deduced maharagus
technique now shukunu predicts that he
will stand back up and heal again
shortly right on cue maharagus wheel
turns in all of its injuries disappear
interested in the shikagami sukuna note
that its first attack was kind of
similar to the mythical legend of yamata
No Orochi while it's supposed to take
use positive energy at second adapted to
the strike with infused cursed energy
that allowed him to break sakuna's guard
additionally Maharaja was able to
recognize Adept and deflect dismantle
both of these advancements occurred
after the eight-handed wheel turned due
to this heck in a dose that furu's
incarnation of the 10 sacred Treasures
which is the Japanese folklore that Mega
meets technique is based around and the
wheel represent a complete cycle of
Harmony having taken his time to allow
this information in front of himself he
comes to the conclusion that maharaja's
technique is the ability to adapt to any
and all phenomena remember in the time
he first fought Mega me he admitted that
if he had Unleashed Maharaja as
originally intended during their fight
it would probably have defeated him
amused sukuna thanks migami for showing
him the way and activates his domain
expansion the prolific malevolent Shrine
when it comes to the demon king of South
saguna has two types of slashing attacks
the default slash dismantle and the
other cleave which can be adjusted
depending on the target's toughness and
cursed energy output to cut them down in
one go most people throughout this
series and the universe objective Kaizen
often make a domain expansion by
realizing their innate domain and
surrounding it with a barrier to give
its structure malevolute shrines differs
from every other domain expansion as it
doesn't create a separate space using a
barrier just so make that a bit more
simple it doesn't have a barrier okay
get this like this is how insanely ahead
of everyone else sakuna truly is the
ability to take your domain and realize
it without using a barrier for structure
it's like an artist trying to create a
masterpiece not just a simple silly old
canvas Masterpiece or like some thing
inside the Sistine Chapel no this is
like some Masterpiece painted on thin
air a truly Divine technique bestowed
upon a demonic Force furthermore sukuna
customizes malevolent Shrine with a
binding vowel that allows an Escape
Route out of its effective range as a
result The Pact also increases the
maximum range of sukuna's domain to 200
meters in order to avoid heading Mega me
though Schooner Narrows that down to
about 140 meters leading loose Schooner
state that until the technique is
deactivated malevolent Shrine will
relentlessly attack anything and range
it will cut down anything with cursed
energy using play and destroy all
inanimate objects with dismantle this
results in massive Devastation on a
steady-wide scale and takes the lives of
numerous civilians who thought they were
safe hiding in a building during the
Rampage outside outside and in the pure
Rage of his attack and not only
decimates waharaga over and over and
over again with an endless barrage of
slashing attacks but over 130 meter
radius of Shibuya is constantly and
continuously pummeled until it is fled
into only dust with buildings and pretty
much the entirety of Shibuya falling to
beds around him sukunu believes the only
way to actually defeat maharaga is the
slaughter it with a new attack before it
can adapt in his eyes Glee fits their
criteria still if maharaka hasn't
adapted to dismantle specifically but a
slashing attacks instead then it only
leaves him a few moments to attack now
before my Horizon as regeneration will
be complete and that is literally what's
going on in order to finish the fight so
good decides to unleash the mysterious
pokenetic ability he used to defeat Joko
earlier instantly after opening up the
tip like weird Dimension or something
screenifies and a mentally powerful fire
arrow and maharaga before the creature
could fully regenerate creating a giant
explosive Pillar of Fire from the impact
that completely annihilates oshigami
after the dust settles and while like
completely immobilized in awe shikamo
just stands there as the king of curses
walks over towards him with a wheel
throwing it next to the pathetic child
Schooner watches as the wheel ends up to
Center greiting second to find the
conclusion of the exorcism ritual
standing there now and wondering what
the freight next storm is even looking
at Sakura tells the curse user to be
gone prompting sugar Mo to flee enjoy so
the reason light for this dude's insane
levels of luck throughout Shibuya in
general and just you know like
everything that we're seeing from him so
far is it because his technique actually
stores up a number of Little Miracles
the little everyday Miracles are erased
from his memory like they it even happen
then stored from when his life is in
danger the markings under his eyes
signify how many miracles are stored up
really enough though and continuing with
the theme of shikamar just being a
complete Nutter he isn't even aware of
the simple fact then like even more of a
Nutter he doesn't run away from the
devastation he decides to run straight
into the devastation of Shibuya not
realizing that sakuru so main expansion
is still completely active now it'd
probably be all right if he had some
Miracles left over but in fact he's
actually used up all of his techniques
remaining luck throughout his battle
with an army and because of that
shikimo's body slides apart having been
completely sliced in half by sakuna's
domain back over with the King man
notices that he doesn't have much
control over yuji's body so in the final
moments he sneakily rushes Mega me to
the Shibuya Tollgate with Yaga and
shohua so he can be healed immediately
after tsukunu returns to dog gonzaka and
relinquishes the control over yuji's
body asking the young sorcerer to take a
good look at the destruction that took
place and instead
foreign
slightly on after the maharaga battle
just to give a little bit of context as
to what was going on there but that
there was just the first time we ever
get to be a witness to the monolith that
is maharaga if you want me to like
individually cover some other fights
from throughout Shibuya like when toji
ruinedagon or the sakoni vs Joker bed or
the heaven before this one then Chuck a
comment down below and if you are new
around here and watch similar content
just like this but for a multitude of
different series then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and push this
video to 5K live so I know you all want
more of course check out the patreon if
you want early access to videos but for
now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and I will see you
all in a bit bye